welcome everyone to today's see far
virtual talk in our series on the theme
science as the exit strategy CFR is a
Canadian based global charitable
organization that convenes extraordinary
minds to address the most important
questions facing science and society we
connect researchers with experts in
government industry and civil society on
timely and relevant issues to develop
new ways of thinking and to promote
change and policy and practice I'm
Rebecca Finley and it is my pleasure to
host today's talk on government
responses to kovat 19 economics politics
and the role of scientific advice with
Professor Tim Bosley Tim is a fellow in
CFR's program on institutions
organization and growth and a school
professor of economics of political
science and W Arthur Lewis professor of
development economics at the London
School of Economics he studies how
institutions shape economic policy
decisions with particular emphasis on
improving the quality of policymaking
and reducing instability he has written
extensively on an impressive range of
important topics in political economy no
surprise my favorite judging by the
title alone is a forthcoming co-authored
publication gender quotas and the crisis
of the mediocre man tim has held several
prominent policy roles including as an
external member of the Bank of England's
Monetary Policy Committee in the UK's
2018 New Year's Honours he was knighted
for his services to economics and public
policy today Tim will discuss the
subtleties of providing science advice
to government during the pandemic a
timely and important topic indeed and we
are honored to have him with us
a few of those keeping notes before we
begin today's session will last 30
minutes if you have a question please
submit it through the Q&A function at
the bottom of your screen
finally this session
being recorded and will be available on
our website next week Tim thank you for
joining us thanks get rid of that car
it's a pleasure it's great to have you
here let's start with a more general
question to frame today's discussion as
we move forward what is political
economy and how does it inform your
thinking around the role of providing
scientific advice to government so
political economy is a field that sort
of emerged in the mainstream of
economics at least the way that I'm
going to talk about it today in the last
25 years trying to understand not just
what good economic policy advice is but
how you actually get good economic
policy outcomes
so it studies the institutional
frameworks in which policy advice is
given and tries to understand what it is
about the institutions of government
that allow the best advice to shine
through it's not enough for economists
to say do X or Y they have to frame that
in a context where it's the politicians
who are going to act and own the policy
and so it's really about studying that
whole process of economic policy
formation in its widest sense great
so you've recently written a column with
one of your colleagues Andris Valeska
and it's titled politicians can't hide
behind scientists forever even in a
pandemic and in it you have a great line
it's politics uninformed by science
quickly becomes quackery
but science unmediated by politics is of
limited use when it comes to solving a
collective action problem such as a
pandemic can you talk a little bit about
this and how this relates directly to
the experience we've been having with
incumbent kovat 19 yeah well that's a
sort of line that I think very much came
out of our study of political economy in
the sense of scientific advice whether
it's science from medics or
epidemiologists or whomever or economic
advice
has to be effective if it's going to
find its way into policy and of course
we hope that policymakers will listen to
their advice but we can't forget that at
the end of the day it's the policy
makers who have to own an advice whether
it being scientific or economic advice
and act upon it in the way they judge I
mean you cannot displace or try to
displace the judgement of the political
process we live in democratic settings a
number of us for very good reasons
because we believe that politicians
should be held to account for the
decisions that are made that there is a
need for politicians to make hard
choices if there's a trade-off between
some gaining and some losing from a
particular policy ultimately the
legitimacy for that trade-off comes from
the public the political process itself
and what I don't think scientists or any
kind of experts can do is to
characterize themselves as somehow
standing above the political process as
if they have some sort of Olympian
judgment that is not not available to
those we elect it's really about working
with the process of realizing you have
to convince the politicians to act and
you have to provide the advice in a
balanced and reasonable way not
pretending that things are necessarily
all going in one direction very often
it's about explaining the pros and cons
but ultimately I think it should it
should enable politics but not displace
politics you know I think that's a
really interesting area to dig into and
I think it speaks to this question of
trust in institutions and governance and
the roles of institutions in society and
how they play and can complan complement
but also conflict with each other I am I
was reflecting on the work that we did
here at CFR with our expert advisory
group on society technology and ethics
and a pandemic when it was clear that we
were trying to balance the technological
possibilities of contact tracing apps
and other novel technologies and the
requirements for governance and
essentially the establishment and
commitment to a sustainable public trust
without public trust the apps would
essentially fail but trust in
institutions is a it's a it's a hard
thing to measure and to understand can
you talk a little bit about that and
what you think may have been some of
some of the impacts of of the pandemic
on the trust in the different
institutions we have in our societies
yeah and let me I think people often say
Trust is hard earned and easily lost as
well and I think that often reflects
some of what we experience but I think
in the pandemic it's been particularly
important the extent of reliance we have
on compliance with various measures that
have been taken and how much trust we
place in in the wider populous to follow
what might be called sensible advice
rather than thinking everything has to
be solved through rules and regulations
so it's kind of getting that balance
right between what you trust citizens to
do and what you trust government to do
is absolutely central and I think what
I've been struck by both with my
experience in the pandemic but also
reflecting on other countries is how the
institutional framework tries to get
that balance right and there are a
number of dimensions I think that are
worth remarking on one is the kind of
transparency of the advice I mean where
is it coming from
on what basis has it been formed is the
evidence base as solid as some people
would claim and it's and it's important
to be - I think be straight with people
about that not to over claim what
evidence can show particularly in areas
where the evidence is less than
clear-cut and you build trust I think
with a certain degree of humility and
honesty but you can't
in the end throw your arms up and say
well we don't know anything that's not
helpful either it's kind of trying to
get what I will regard as a reasonable
default position a position you can
defend short of evidence moving you away
from it and I think the art of it and
you can get to this in different ways is
is to hit upon a default option that is
supportable by evidence and you and you
don't feel compelled to keep shifting
ground because if you go to the wrong
place and evidence is repeatedly coming
up to say you're in the wrong place it
will undermine trust again in the whole
system not just in that specific piece
of advice and so as much as possible you
try and get those default positions
right as quickly and early as possible a
little bit about what we've seen over
the last several months with Koba 19 is
that there's quite a dynamic nature to
that interplay as the evidence changes
when the health advice evolves and we
see that tension between providing
science advice and the role of the
politician and the institutions of
government so there's a really
interesting dynamic around this rapid
response mechanism and I wanted to talk
to you a little bit about Dell which is
a group that's been put together that
you're a member of in the UK led by the
Royal Society
I think Dell stands for data evaluation
and learning for viral epidemics if I
look at my notes and it's really trying
to apply data evaluation and system and
synthesis to different approaches that
have been taken and it's an
interdisciplinary group as well but
quite rapidly developing this this
knowledge and information into
government and the actions that move
forward can you talk a little bit about
how that has worked and what you think
some of the benefits of that might have
been and maybe potentially some of the
risks yeah so I mean many ways delve is
a reflection of the what safar's mantra
is because it's trying to be issue
driven and bring expertise regardless of
discipline together based around around
issues so I felt quite at home being a
part of that even though there's an
economist I'm in a small minority that
the disciplines the many disciplines
involved epidemiology Public Health
Medical Sciences of different kinds so
it's been a very interesting experience
trying to bring a group
people together to work on problems and
to produce reports which we hope will be
useful to informing policy an example
would be the report we did on testing
tracing and isolation another one on the
use of face masks as other reports in in
process so trying to sort of look at the
different approaches disciplines take to
evidence what kind of evidence they
value let me give you an example I don't
think in a pandemic like this you can
put too much weight on randomized
control trials not because they're not
useful when you can have them but many
of the pieces of advice you're giving
simply don't have an RCT evidence base
so if you said well we're only going to
do those things that are proven by
enemy's control trials we're certainly
not going to get very far when the
degree of uncertainty and lack of
appropriate knowledge exists so it's
kind of then working together and saying
well what evidence is persuasive and and
also getting a wider a wider perspective
on on on the evidence to what extent we
want to bring the economic cost in
alongside some of the the costs to
infection you know there's been this
balancing act which I'm sure you're
familiar with in Canada between trying
to get the public health right and
trying to get the economics right
without without compromising either too
much and and again through conversations
within within a multidisciplinary
environment we can we can sort of start
to speak each other's language or
understand each other's language but
ultimately the view is we need to put
out there the best of thinking that we
can find and and then input that into
the policy process yeah it's it's very
helpful I think I think the interesting
approach to to look out to different
jurisdictions so I often think about
this is one of the things that CFR finds
really valuable in our process is having
research programs that are made up of
senior academic leaders who are based in
different institutions and different
disciplines and in different countries
being able to bring that together we
were able to hold an international
consultation with several
individuals based in the UK as part of
the work we did on the society
technology and ethics report as well how
do you find that reaching into your
international networks understanding
what's happening outside of the UK to
then be able to provide advice into the
UK government well I think I mean I
think goes goes without saying I'm sure
you know that we're we are all academics
typically embedded in international
networks we're all that frustrated that
we're house bound now and can't be
participating in international
conferences I think zoom has provided a
platform at least for us to could stay
in start in close communication with our
academic colleagues around the world
because most of our disciplines are
highly internationalized and therefore
we are all the time trying to look and
see where the best the best knowledge is
even though you know you working in a
country context as we are I mean we're
trying to feed into the UK policy
response many much of the time it's what
have we learned from country X or Y
about how they they approached it and
can we feed that in one of the experts
saying why are they saying eventually
something different you know is there a
justifiable reason for taking a
different position does it just reflect
the cultural or institutions of another
country so when it's constantly trying
to synthesize and understand there's
different perspectives to try and kind
of work out what to conclude from that
it's more I mean I slightly speaking
against the title of the seminar it's
more of an art than a science I would
say being able to sift the evidence and
get that right but at the end of the day
the science is a big input into the art
if you like fair enough that makes it
that makes a lot of sense so one area
that you and I have just touched on
briefly was around the world of the
private sector so there are many actors
in an economy all of them have different
roles can you talk a little bit about
the role that you see of the firms and
the private sector as part of the
pandemic response so we think about
public health and the
cows response we think about economic
stimulus and innovation as a form of
recovery out of the pandemic but what
have you seen in terms of the dynamics
around the private sector engaging with
the government or being part of the
public health response there's a couple
of things on that I'd like to say what
one is the sort of direct involvement in
the private sector trying to deliver a
kind of recovery phase there is little
doubt that we will have to get the
private sector back into some kind of
decent shape to provide the jobs and
livelihoods for people who've been
affected by the pandemic but equally
there will be a different world out
there one where business as usual will
not be possible in many sectors of the
economy at least for the foreseeable
future - we hopefully get a vaccine or a
more effective treatment and so it's a
case of trying to work with with
business to to make the best of what is
a difficult situation for example what
kind of testing protocols does one want
in place how does one encourage them are
they a matter of voluntary compliance or
compulsion I think we all think that in
the end trying to get people to do
things voluntarily is advantageous but
that's not always feasible so you have
to decide where there's the limelight
regulation and volunteerism
but many firms that particularly those
that want to get back to normal business
have stepped up and started voluntarily
to engage in public health measures and
not an entirely frivolous example is the
professional soccer to you football to
us leagues which have basically in order
to be able to be allowed to play again
have put in very rigorous testing
regimes for players and staff because
they realized that was the only route
back to some kind of normal operation of
their business even though in fact all
the fixtures have played behind closed
doors so that's one aspect the other
aspect which I mentioned briefly is the
provision of data so you know we we've
been very clear in this pandemic how
much have one of wealth of intelligence
and information resides with the private
sector whether they be mobile phone
companies that
because to put up tracing apps or
whatever through financial firms that
can have a much more up-to-date and
up-to-the-minute picture of the impact
of the of the pandemic on the economy so
one needs to form sort of public-private
partnerships to both access and analyze
data now raises quite a few issues not
least around data privacy and so it's
not it's not altogether straightforward
to know how you how you do that but it
has been I think an interesting feature
of the pandemic that need to forge those
strong partnerships and to together to
try and do the best and I think some of
this will outlive the the the pandemic
that new ways of looking at the economy
through the lens of the data that the
private sector has or looking at public
health measures through the same lens
will become something we tweet we may
say in the end you know we want we want
to maintain this this is this is
important for creating more effective
intervention and better societies that's
a really interesting point I think we've
certainly seen in Canada that the wealth
of data that we have within our health
systems many of them at the provincial
level really a really renewed
understanding of the value of the data
and the capacity for it to inform
research and decision making you know
both in terms of when it when it doesn't
work well and then you know in terms of
Public Health surveillance and otherwise
but then also when you know really the
benefit in thinking about how do we
sustain and support those data
infrastructures in a way that will allow
the research and work that needs to be
done it's a whole other question when
you think about the private sector and
as you rightly admit you have all sorts
of constraints consent based privacy
policies and otherwise that exists
that data so what does that mean in
terms of thinking about how to integrate
that or not
into government systems as well and I
think that will be one of I I think that
is going to be one of the legacies that
will come out of this time will be some
understanding about what data and what
systems we need to have within our
government structures and then also and
will what the role of the private sector
might be in that regard I want to we've
got one question from from the audience
that I want to use drills in to the
point you made earlier Tim around around
public trust and transparency and the
question is really that oftentimes a
politician will say that their their
advice is based on science but they may
not in fact indicate where they got the
scientific advice from our what the
evidence might be to support that advice
so how does the way in which a
politician communicates about the
science and the evidence base for their
information how does that affect the
trust that citizens have in that
information and in that advice I think
this has been is a very interesting
question because this has been I think
one of the major areas where we be
learning as we go
you know how you through through the
pandemic in many countries people who
are scientist I anticipated it become
sort of public figures because
scientists so because politicians in
particular have found it convenient to
put them on pedestals and to have them
directly communicate with the public in
order for them to try and answer
questions concerns that the public have
so so sometimes instead of the
politician being the mouthpiece for this
is the advice they you know if you if
you ever tuned in to the broadcast we
have in the UK the press conferences
you're very often finding the politician
will hand off the question directly to a
scientist and say this is one for the
scientist now please answer them there's
no the scientists can't hide at that
point because they either state an
opinion or the
so then you can't just say a scientist
believes you really you know figure out
who's who's saying what but I think
there's a sort of wider background
concern and this is why it's been
evolving through the pandemic because
initially the main scientific body in
the UK Sage there was not even any
transparency about who sat on that body
and then at one point they were forced
to publish the names and and as time
goes by people are asking for even more
information maybe they should publish
the minutes for those of us who used to
work in central banking will be familiar
with this I used to publish our central
bank minutes after every policy decision
to communicate to the public why we were
reaching a decision but now now that may
become a feature of these more
institutionalized scientific bodies that
they're they have to publish minutes and
then maybe they also have to publish
some of the sources for that those
minutes which particular studies because
as we know it's rarely that you have
just a single study that's going to
convince you to shift policy but if
that's really what shifter policy people
should be honest about that what was the
evidence that was decisive and so this
is a this has been a very interesting
area to watch evolving countries will
learn from each other they'll look at
what systems are in place and decide
whether they want the more the system in
which the politicians have put more on
the pedestal less on the pedestal quoted
not quoted but but I think because this
is all hitters in such a short time
we're very much learning on on the job
as far as that goes
absolutely so really interesting
question around the politicization of
science of bodies so we've seen for
example in the u.s. around face masks
and face masks where in that there's
that's become a rather partisan issue so
how you know what advice would you give
to scientists who were providing policy
advice
how does want to stay away from or to
avoid the politicization of some of the
advice they're providing well the sort
of one level of politicization that I
think is in the hands of the individuals
concerned and that's the extent to which
they want to speak out or not against
what is palpably government policy I
think once you do that you've kind of
crossed the line and you have in whether
you like it or not become part of the
political process and I think that's
always been an issue that scientists or
economists or anyone else face once you
once you become oppositional you do
become part of the political process but
I think that the way kind of more
generally I think about this is to come
back to this idea of a default policy
that I think there's sort of two stances
you can take one is that this policy is
contrary is contravening of view of what
the evidence says is a good policy
that's a very strong statement versus
saying well I can't provide compelling
evidence to move from this policy I'm
not sure it's right or wrong but so I
think there's a sort of difference
between saying we know this is wrong
versus we don't have sufficient evidence
to move away from it and I think it's
when you cross that line into yes I know
this is wrong and you're willing to
state so publicly that you become as
they say part of the political process
but very often science or economics or
anything else you study it's not so
clear-cut that you can denounce
something as evidently a bad policy so a
good example is the face mask I'll just
mention this briefly because I think
early on in the pandemic the view should
probably have been taken that face masks
wearing face masks in confined spaces
was was the right policy that wasn't the
policy we took in the UK I don't know
for sure what you what you decided in
Canada now it's not because I could
prove or anyone else could prove that
wearing a face mask is such a great idea
I mean you can certainly hard to believe
it's a bad idea but it's certainly not
evidently proven that it's a good idea
so that shouldn't become the default
policy that once you take the default
policy to be you should wear face.you so
you shouldn't wear
masks you shift about burden of proof
and and that's a very different
proposition which again I think is very
hard to prove so so I think making those
choices about where you think the
presumption lies can make a lot of
difference to the way the public debate
evolved okay we have just a few minutes
left but I really I just would love you
to take a moment because clearly
providing policy advice has been a part
of your academic career right from the
very earliest days you've been involved
in many different forms of providing
policy advice and I wondered if you
could just sort of reflect on that I
think there'd be a lot of researchers on
the call on this talk who would be
interested to hear why was that
important to your academic career and if
there was an experience that was
particularly rewarding what was it so I
think the time it dawned on me more than
any other time was when I was a
policymaker you mentioned I was in
Central Bank during the financial crisis
and of course there I was an effective
policymaker taking part in the response
to that crisis only in a narrow sense of
the monetary policy at the time but a
couple of things occurred to me that
reflect on your question one was that as
a someone whose that was three years of
my life or all the rest of my life I've
been essentially in academic but what
was interesting about that experience in
terms of my academic life was realizing
that there's two things that I think
academics can really contribute and
that's often to provide a framework for
thinking about the policy issues which
well it won't necessarily resolve the
issue because the issue is itself very
complex you can by Framing in a
particular way make transparent to those
who have to make decisions kind of what
the pros and cons are broadly of taking
different stances and where the evidence
would definitely say you shouldn't do
something versus where it doesn't prove
you shouldn't do something but it might
be prudent to do it so I think one of
the things that I've always found
rewarding if you like engagement in
policy is where you think you can you
can make a contribution by framing an
issue in a in a in a particular in a
particular way so so I think that's
that's a valuable part of what we do and
link to that academics can take a long
term view I mean even in the pandemic
where we're you know we know we got to
make policy this week next week probably
every week for the next six months I
still think lifting your head up a bit
and thinking about the long-term
implications is incredibly important and
if you get too sucked into the
day-to-day policy you often kind of
start to lose sight of the bigger
picture you know where is it we're going
why are we going and I think that's a
very valuable asset that academics
probably sometimes underestimate now
admittedly you can't say I'll come back
in 20 years and give you an answer but I
think still being able to do slightly
longer-term thinking is really very very
important absolutely critical and in a
kind of great spot for us to conclude
today's discussion on thank you so much
Tim that's all the time we have for
today and so before everyone signs off
I'd like to thank all of you for joining
us and I'd especially like to thank you
Tim for your insights today dreamily
extremely interesting and useful
conversation thank you so much I'd also
like to thank Rachel orchard Parker for
her inspiration and organization of
today's talk as well as Daniel patch
nello and Jacqui Sullivan in the
proverbial control room please visit our
website see far CA to find out more
about the series interview a recording
of this talk along with previously
recorded ones thank you all for joining
us and goodbye
you